en la última serie de vídeos nos
quedamos que el banco central chino
el banco central chino
estaban tratando de asegurarse de que el
yuan no se aprecie demasiado la forma en
la que ellos hicieron esto es que
compraron todos los dólares sobrantes
usando ioannes que ellos imprimieron lo
que ellos hicieron fue imprimir yuanes
esto lo voy a escribir en un color azul
ellos imprimieron ciones imprimieron you
want
que su moneda y usaron esos yuanes que
imprimieron para comprar dólares en el
mercado abierto y lo que ésta ocasiona
es aumentar la demanda de dólares y
mantener bajo el precio del yuan
y primero en yuanes y compraron dólares
compraron dólares y como vimos tienen
que seguir haciendo esto para que puedan
mantener al yuan deflación ado y para
mantener el dólar inflado y así mantener
el balance comercial a su favor pero
mientras hacen esto ellos van aumentando
sus reservas de dólares están aumentando
esta pila de dólares y mencionamos en el
vídeo anterior no mantienen una gran
caja fuerte llena de dólares
ellos los usan para comprar activos van
a comprar activos líquidos y otro tipo
de activos pero el principal activo que
van a comprar es letras del tesoro de
los eeuu así que toman estos dólares y
compran letras del tesoro y déjenme
dibujar los otros activos que también
pueden comprar hay dos tipos de personas
un tipo compra letras del tesoro de los
eeuu del gobierno tesoro de los eeuu y
ellos van a tener esto cuando necesitan
tomar prestado dinero y hay otro tipo de
personas que ya compraron este tipo de
letras del tesoro de los eeuu vamos a
dibujarlos por acá aquí hay otro tipo de
personas que ya son dueños de las letras
del tesoro le vamos a dibujar un
sombrero a mejor tiene un poquito de
cabello no sé algún bigote y aquí vamos
a hacer un pequeño resumen cuando el
gobierno de los eeuu quiere tomar
prestado dinero las personas le dan
dinero al gobierno de los eeuu ellos le
dan dinero aquí voy a dibujar unos
billetes de dólares ellos le dan dinero
al tesoro de los eeuu y éste a su vez
les da a ellos un pagaré les da un
pagaré este pagaré es a lo que nos
referimos como una letra del tesoro
agarre y derecho al poseedor de este
pedazo de papel obtener intereses por
parte del tesoro dependiendo de qué tipo
de letra es la que haya comprado y sobre
cuál periodo de tiempo tenga validez
este se ha hecho un vídeo completo al
respecto de estos detalles y en algún
momento del futuro el tesoro de los eeuu
les va a pagar el dinero que le
prestaron más los intereses así que esta
es una letra del tesoro una letra del
tesoro si es a corto plazo o un mono del
tesoro si es a largo plazo en este caso
es un bono del tesoro así que el banco
central chino con este exceso de dólares
puede comprar cualquiera de estas dos
opciones cuando el tesoro de los eeuu
necesita fondos lo que hace es que va a
tomar estos pagarés y los va a poner en
subasta y se los va a dar a aquella
persona que esté dispuesta a recibir el
menor interés así que permítanme ponerlo
de esta manera lo que ellos pueden hacer
dar el dinero directamente al tesoro de
los eeuu y este a su vez les da letras o
bonos del tesoro por medio de una
subasta les dan ellos dinero y el tesoro
de los eeuu les da uno
o lo puede comprar a alguien que ya
tiene uno de estos bonos o letras del
tesoro y este es un mercado abierto
bastante líquido ellos les pueden dar a
estas personas dinero y estos les
transferirán los pagarés a este banco
central y qué es lo que pasa en el banco
central lo que sucede en esencia cuando
el banco central chino hace esto de
imprimir yuanes y comprar dólares es
esencialmente prestarle al tesoro de los
eeuu quizás esto les parezca algo
confuso o quizás muy rebuscado pero en
esencia todo esto lo que ocasiona es que
el banco central chino el banco central
chino
le da prestado dinero al gobierno de los
eeuu
al gobierno de los eeuu
y esto cómo afecta a eeuu además de que
en lugar de verle a personas le lleva al
banco central chino pero cuál es el
efecto neto de tener a este jugador acá
que es un jugador bastante significativo
que con bastante agresividad está
dispuesto a pagar por bonos o letras del
tesoro de los eeuu cuál es el efecto de
esto como vimos en el vídeo de la curva
de rendimiento mientras las personas
quieran hacerle un préstamo menor será
la tasa de interés y les puedo mostrar
un ejemplo muy sencillo de esto si yo
estoy buscando tomar prestado y no estoy
hablando de naciones estoy hablando de
mí ahora digamos que yo estoy acá aquí
me voy a dibujar y estoy buscando tomar
prestados 10 dólares quiero yo quiero
tomar prestados 10 dólares y yo les digo
a ver quién de ustedes está dispuesto a
hacerme el mejor ofrecimiento para
prestarme 10 dólares y yo les pagaré la
siguiente semana y algunos de ustedes
puede venir y decirme bueno yo te puedo
prestar tus 10 dólares con un interés al
10% semanal así que yo te presto y tú me
puedes pagar 11 dólares la siguiente
semana que sería el 10 por ciento de
interés a la semana eran 10 dólares
ahorita y yo les regreso 11 dólares la
próxima semana y eso si yo decidiera
aceptar su ofrecimiento pero no se
imaginó que aquí maría se acerca y le
dice yo puedo ofrecerte algo mejor está
que se dibuja no es mariah pueda ser lo
mejor que el hombre naranja de aquí
arriba yo te presto 10 dólares y tú me
puedes pagar
donde puedes pagar
10 dólares con 50 centavos la siguiente
semana noten qué es lo que está pasando
aquí dos personas están dispuestas a
prestarme dinero y ambas buscan tener
alguna ganancia de esos diez dólares si
él fuera el único que se ofreciera a
prestarme yo iría con él aceptaría su
propuesta pero llegó ella y me dice no
yo te presto diez dólares y tú solo me
tienes que devolver diez dólares con 50
centavos la siguiente semana pues a mí
me conviene porque son 50 centavos menos
que tengo que pagar y mientras más gente
allá ofreciendo esto pues se va a volver
más competitivo y yo obtendré una tasa
de interés menor incluso se pueden
imaginar que entra a una tercera persona
cristian espérame tantito
yo tengo diez dólares vamos a dibujar a
esta tercera persona que dice yo tengo
diez dólares y sabes que yo te lo puedo
prestar y tú me puedes pagar tú me
puedes pagar
a 10 dólares con 25 centavos la
siguiente semana y en este caso yo
aceptaría la propuesta de la tercera
persona me conviene más mientras más
personas estén dispuestas a prestarme
dinero será más bajo el rango de mi tasa
de interés otra forma de verlo es que
mientras más grande sea la fuente de
dinero para ser prestado
para ser prestado
significa que tendremos humanos vamos a
verlo de diferente manera podemos verlo
como un costo de préstamo
menor costo de préstamo menor
qué es otra forma de decir que es un
menor interés es menor el interés lo
pueden ver como que es dinero más barato
porque le cuesta menos tomar prestado al
final cuando tengo que hacer el pago más
el interés y ahora que me ocasiona esto
ese es un ejemplo muy pequeño en donde
estoy yo y quiero tomar prestados 10
dólares y hay varias personas que se
ofrecen a prestarme los con diferentes
tasas de interés mientras más personas
hayan yo puedo tener acceso a un menor
interés y tomamos esta misma noción pero
la aplicamos a un nivel macro en este
caso mientras más personas estén
dispuestas a prestarle al gobierno de
los eeuu dinero la tasa de interés de
los pagarés va a ser menor así que el
efecto neto de tener un gran comprador
que es este banco central es que al tema
de ellos todos estos dólares acumulados
y usarlos ellos mismos
todos estos dólares para comprar bonos o
letras del tesoro va a bajar la tasa de
interés para los tesoros
el efecto neto es que el tesoro de los
eeuu va a tener una tasa de interés
menor
esto que va a significar vamos a dejarlo
muy claro los chinos
bonos o letras del tesoro de eeuu
del gobierno de los eeuu
por lo tanto el gobierno de los eeuu va
a tener un costo de
préstamo mucho menos
y esto tiene varios efectos secundarios
muy interesantes
uno de estos efectos secundarios es que
es más fácil
para el gobierno de los eeuu
y financiar déficits financiar déficits
no tienen que pagar mucho en interés
eso significa que pueden gastar más
también pueden dar más pagos a los
ciudadanos de los eeuu o disminuir los
impuestos cualquiera de los dos así que
para el gobierno de los eeuu va a poder
gastar más no tendrán que recabar tantos
impuestos
pueden bajar los impuestos no tienen que
gastar tanto pagando los intereses otra
cosa que sucede con el tesoro de los
eeuu es que la tasa de interés de todos
los demás es también baja pues este es
un punto de referencia para todas las
demás tasas de interés y les recomiendo
que vean el vídeo de la curva de
rendimiento pues esto aclara muchos de
los temas que estamos hablando aquí y
ustedes me dirán bueno que acaso la
reserva federal no tiene una tasa de
interés pues si la tiene pero aplica
sólo a operaciones a corto plazo si
ustedes van a tomar prestado dinero de
su banco de un día para otro se usará
esa tasa de interés pero si el gobierno
de los estados unidos está tomando
prestado dinero durante 5 ó 10 ó 20 años
la tasa de interés va a ser la del
mercado y éste se va a establecer por un
mecanismo de mercado muy similar al que
les mostré anteriormente así que una
deuda de los eeuu por 5 ó 10 o 20 años
va a ser mucho más barata y todas las
deudas en eeuu se volverán más baratas
esto ocasiona que toda la deuda
toda la deuda
en los eeuu
sean más baratas y hay dos maneras en
las que ustedes pueden analizar esto una
vez viéndolo desde un nivel muy
superficial algunas personas pueden
decir mira está esta empresa general
electric que es apenas un poquito más
riesgosa que la del gobierno de los eeuu
si el gobierno de los eeuu sólo tiene
que pagar un 3% en una deuda de 10 años
pues quizás general electric sólo tengo
que pagar 1.3 por ciento más que eso el
gobierno federal es una línea base para
las tasas de interés de los demás por lo
que las demás compañías pueden ser un
poquito más arriesgadas que están otra
forma de pensar en ello es si lo vemos
aquí arriba el gobierno chino está
inundado de dólares y los está vertiendo
dentro de el mercado del tesoro de los
eeuu así que esta persona de a quién
tiene más dólares y no va a usar letras
del tesoro porque piensa que son muy
caras y el interés es muy bajo así que
él va a tomar sus dólares y se los va a
prestar a alguien más los dólares ahí
siguen pero a lo mejor van a general
electric
a lo mejor él tiene una compañía de
tarjetas de crédito y se los va a
prestar a los consumidores en general
toda la deuda en los eeuu se vuelve más
barata y ya que vimos todos estos puntos
cuál va a ser su efecto neto cuál es el
efecto neto de esto pues que hay más
dólares para prestar en los eeuu más
dólares que las personas pueden tomar
prestados el gobierno está gastando más
o que el gobierno va a bajar los
impuestos pues como resultado la gente
va a tener más dinero en sus bolsillos
porque tienen un trabajo en el gobierno
o porque han recibido algún pago o
tendrán más dinero porque van a pagar
menos impuestos o quizás tengan más
dinero en sus bolsillos porque es más
fácil para ellos poner deuda en sus
tarjetas de crédito o pudieron
refinanciar su hipoteca todo esto
todo esto
nos lleva a tener más efectivo
más efectivo en los bolsillos de los
estadounidenses y bueno esto es algo
ambiguamente bueno porque está basado en
deuda no es un efectivo libre de deuda
así que es más efectivo en los bolsillos
de los estadounidenses pero financiado
con deuda financiado con deuda
con deuda y esa deuda puede ocurrir a
nivel de tarjetas de crédito o puede
estar ocurriendo a un nivel corporativo
o puede estar ocurriendo indirectamente
a nivel del gobierno pero todo esto está
ocurriendo porque el gobierno chino está
dispuesto a comprar bonos o netas del
tesoro lo que significa que china está
dispuesta a darle prestado al gobierno
de los eeuu china está manteniendo su
moneda baja de manera artificial y esto
lo logra comprando dólares tomando a sus
dólares e invirtiendo los a los eeuu y
éstos eventualmente terminarán en las
manos de los ciudadanos de este país y
lo que ellos van a hacer pues van a
comprar cosas chinas baratas que se
mantienen artificialmente baratas debido
a que su moneda es más baja por lo que
ellos compran cosas chinas
artificialmente baratas y ustedes saben
que ellos tienen un costo laboral mucho
más barato pero va a ser aún más barato
para los estadounidenses de lo que sería
si su moneda
vida el valor que debería y el efecto
neto final de todo esto que acabamos de
analizar es que los chinos le prestan
dinero a los americanos que éstos a su
vez lo usarán para comprar más cosas de
china